so you have a committee to commands with
this game this is significant until dawn
takes 80's and 90's horror movie tropes
and wraps them into a
choose-your-own-adventure
it's sort of like the film cabin in the
woods only you're in control of the
story reunited on a snowy mountain a
year after the death of their two
friends eight teenagers find themselves
dealing with not only clashing
personalities but a creature roaming the
woods ghosts a murderer
you name it you play as all 18s in turn
navigating harrowing situations and
making tough choices and where to go and
how to behave as you explore the
mountain your primary way of interacting
with the environment is through glowing
objects you'll turn power on open gates
climb walls and ladders interactions are
limited to these specific set pieces
which is frustrating and sometimes dull
but until Dawn has tons of hidden
secrets designed to push the plot
forward scattered around are two special
kinds of objects clues and totems clues
offer insight into what's happening
leaving a trail of narrative breadcrumbs
they fill in backstory and are key to
fully understanding the horror plaguing
the area you must look through every
nook and cranny if you want to find them
all I played the game through multiple
times and on my second run I still found
clues I hadn't seen previously clues
that surprised me I made the story more
heartbreaking and more shocking
unfortunately until Dawn's main story
becomes predictable you'll know what's
happening although the characters won't
that's why you need those clues each one
equips the teens with knowledge to make
more informed decisions or cheat death
they will talk about these clues showing
these small pieces do matter to plot and
mesh in your gameplay with the story in
one instance a totem showed a character
petting a wolf when I encounter the wolf
I decline to harm him and he became my
ally later on in another missing a clue
in a corner resulted in agonizing death
for my favorite character it upset me in
the neck
I'm around I search to save him oh my
god we got to get out I understand what
a paycheck this is insane we need to go
get help but death is inevitable and
until dawn and that's where totems come
in each presents a peak of an event that
could happen later on however it's
entirely possible that your choices
along until Dawn's branching paths never
take you in that direction the totems
show ways a character could die hidden
threats and other suggested actions
I found totems very useful in scenarios
I recognized from a totem I tried not to
make wrong moves
it's a clever way to forewarn players
hoping to avoid cheap deaths a note on
this though it is possible to finish the
game with all eight characters alive or
all of them dead all right until dawn is
all about its butterfly effect tiny
consequences throughout the game caused
a ripple turning the tide of major
events I played until dawn a few times
and I didn't expect the long-lasting
effect the tiniest choices had what
playing is one character choosing not to
side with his girlfriend in a fight
meant she verbally abused him for the
remainder of the game which in turn
affected his dialogue towards her and
how willingly he helped in multiple
playthroughs one character died
different ways first she didn't find a
weapon when I missed a clue in a hurry
to escape the second time I chose to
have her break off from the group to
follow a voice and she met her demise
it's easy to track this butterfly effect
during play to a menu shows each major
decision and whenever something happens
resulting from this choice the game
advertises a butterfly effect update the
constant updates are very in-your-face
but when playing a second time I
constantly referred back to them making
different decisions to save or sacrifice
characters the performance isn't until
dawn are incredible in like any horror
movie you find your favorites root for
their survival the desk depicted are
pretty gross
and at the same time it's entertaining
crafting the narrative to your liking
fantastic acting aside there are moments
when visuals get really jank camera
angles are fixed and get frustrating
during some navigation when walking up a
mountain the camera will follow you
around a corner but stop and wait is you
move further up and out of sight the
facial animations are audit x as some
expressions like a grimace don't
translate well with mocap there's just
too much team whoa gosh I didn't expect
to have as much fun as I did with until
dawn I was looking for a horror movie
where I chose who lived and died but
until dawn gives you that and more how
much of the narrative you unravel is
dependent on how diligent you are and
it's easy to feel paranoid with every
choice in a game where something as
innocuous as not harming a bird could
lessen the dangers that confront you
later it's fun to sweat the small things
despite the story revealing its
intentions early on it's worth playing
multiple times because you'll never end
with the same group alive it's a
thoughtful game that elevates it's
simple controls and tropes into an
experience you can't resist again and
yeah hey